let's see what else we got here
this is the price from South Bend
Indiana
South Bend and I've been over there to
Mishawaka as well
and I got
um
stuck in a
uh I got stuck in a townhouse with a man
who was
um chain smoking cigars
and I got stuck in there for a couple
days with him let's hear more
[Music]
but I was just curious
turn off sir
uh you know something oh yeah turn offs
brother I feel it and I would say
probably chatty
if somebody's
just being too chatty why are they doing
it
don't do it
um orange perfume if somebody's wearing
orange perfume
I don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it that much senior citizen perfume
a lot of some of those have younger
women wearing senior citizen perfume I
don't understand that you can wear it
when you get there you know
um
I prefer if a woman doesn't work or know
the value will work I'm out I like a
hard-working woman
um
no she don't have to have three jobs but
I like a woman who just knows the value
of work
um
what else oh turn off for me can't swim
if you can't swim honey
I mean the Earth is 80 water
so
if there's you know if there's a tsunami
and you trying to get on my back bye
[__] I'm doing me
I'm new with may you know what I'm
saying I you know
I ain't your floaty
I ain't nobody floaty
so yeah if she can't swim I'm out
and what else
oh if she has way too many dietary
restrictions
I'm out
I'd love to discuss it more but no I
wouldn't I'm out I'm upstairs workers
so I think those are some of the things
that I really like and um
that
that are some of my things about women
you know and if women if a woman hate
butterscotches if you hate
butterscotch's baby
then I'm out
cause I love them I love a damn bee
Scotch for Daddy